Hillary Clinton is starting a podcast
and many people know my affinity for
Hillary Clinton and I don't even mean as
a joke I do respect you can't be a
student of history and not have some
level I don't want to use the word
affection but you you are in awe of
certain people's abilities certain
people's abilities even if they are
murderers even if they have sexual
problems as her husband seems to but you
look at a guy like that it was a Rhodes
Scholar smart guy the human brain is
fascinating some of the most talented
people in the world have things that are
deeply wrong with them Michael Jackson
you know maybe Woody Allen I don't know
maybe I you know allegedly like
brilliant people insanely talented
people in in certain cases have real
issues you know Bill Clinton was an
incredibly gifted political mind watch
his speeches watch his ability to
communicate with people he would go into
a room and make these you know single
mothers think he gave a [ __ ] and he
wanted to [ __ ] he didn't give a [ __ ] he
wanted a [ __ ]
it's a different it's an amazing skill
set and there's very few people that
I've seen have things that approximate
that skill set up close
some people are magic I've met a few
people that are magic have those Quatro
Carmichael comedian producer has a
quality of magic where when you are
talking to him you feel like you're the
only person he's talking to or thinking
about or he's he makes you feel very
good now he's a good guy I'm not saying
that this is not you know who he is but
I'm also saying that like it's a skill
it's a skill some of these people are
great salesmen some of them are great
politicians none of the words because
the word salesman makes you think of
somebody like me you know it doesn't
make you what I'm what I'm trying to
describe is hard to really put into
words because it's it's a magical
quality that certain people have star
power whatever you want to say it's
infectious you want them to like you you
trust them you Hillary Clinton did not
have any of that she didn't have it
her husband had it Hillary has a lot of
other qualities she's a great deal maker
she's a great behind-the-scenes operator
she's you know a tough [ __ ] she knows
how to you know string up a noose
metaphorically but Clinton was elected
the governor of art you know he went to
where did he go Georgetown Yale Harvard
Oxford Yale Oxford Georgetown his
mentors that got him Carroll Quigley who
wrote a book called tragedy in Hope
which is this huge epic history of the
world and our time talks about you know
the eastern establishment the
anglo-american
Empire everything it's really a history
of everything you know people have put
it you know as uh you know it's like
they've said the genre is you know
conspiracy literature but it's really
it's it's much more than that
it's really an amazing compendium of all
of these councils and all of these
groups of people that have shaped and
continue to shape the world and that was
Clinton's mentor and Clinton was elected
to governor of Arkansas I believe 31 he
was like the boy governor he was a young
governor right about the time the CIA
was flying you know planes for a coke
and Amina Arkansas and dropping off that
so that we could put it into inner
cities and fund the Contras it was you
know that's there's so much evidence of
that and Clinton was you know like hey
you know kept his mouth shut
there were two boys who were hanging out
down by where one of those drops was
happening and I think their name were
like Kevin Liles and Don something I
don't know the boys on the tracks was
the documentary about it or the film
about it and they and they were
somewhere in this secret airfield or
wherever where they were they had
witnessed something they should not have
witnessed and then like many young teens
do they ended up smoking marijuana and
falling asleep on the train tracks
well I've smoked a lot of weed and I've
never fallen asleep on the train tracks
but this is the story you have their
names Don Henry and Kevin Ives yeah
Kevin Ives and Don Henry and they ended
up you know falling asleep on the train
tracks and getting killed nobody bought
this but you know they witnessed
something they shouldn't have witnessed
this is when you know and his Clinton
the governor at this time I'm pretty
sure he is yes he is yeah
the governor of Arkansas during this
time so again this is you know his bona
fides are established here he then is
mentored and guided you know then he
ends up I'd like to build a bird
conference again is the governor of
Arkansas what is the state of Arkansas I
have to say about International Finance
not much but he ends up there and then
he ends up getting elected to the
presidency twice and defeating George HW
Bush friend of the show done many
episodes on him many episodes on the
Bush family don't worry about them they
get a poppin you know
yeah there's no shrinking violets over
there they're deeply connected much
deeper than the Clintons the Clintons
were like trash you know in in the sense
that they were you know being you but
the people that make the Clintons like
an idea to as a joke you make them like
into a boogeyman they're not running the
show they are they're they're a moral
people that is why I do it because I
want you to know how amoral your leaders
are but when it comes you know the
bushes were deeply connected to the
intelligence apparatus deeply but
Hillary is now starting a podcast my
friend Hillary I mean I don't want to do
a million hack jokes about her podcast
it's just here's what I will say how far
the mighty have fallen
[Laughter]
how far the mighty have fallen from the
world stage from murdering Vince Foster
from arranging the suicides of many of
your Secret Service people from the
Clinton Global Initiative laundering
dark money from all over the world from
the Epstein's from the islands from
little st. James to reading an ad for
blue cheese how the mighty have fallen